will Stargate be ruined by Amazon
executives
possibly welcome to Sidetrack your
Sci-Fi TV and movie channel
[Music]
so I look at as many of my comments on
the channel as I possibly can and I get
a lot saying basically that if Stargate
is announced it will be destroyed by
awoke Hollywood now if you are a regular
site tracker you'll know I hate that
term I don't like it I actually think
most sci-fi should be awake to things
like racism sexism the struggles of the
transgender Community
etc etc that actually sci-fi is at its
best when it's awake to these problems
and when it uses the metaphor of sci-fi
to actually talk about these things but
Amazon particularly recently has made a
couple of TV shows that aren't the best
and aren't exactly loved by the fans
that so wanted these projects done Lord
of the Rings the rings of power is the
obvious one and that I get the most
comments about but also things like
Wheel of Time both of these projects
have really serious problems from day
one that actually then did really give a
lot of the hardcore people that shout
woke an awful lot of ammunition to throw
at the projects both of these TV series
were really hated by quite a lot of
people before they were even aired and I
do not want to see that again for
Stargate now I just did a video talking
about how I want Brad Wright to be
involved in some way to also calm down a
lot of the audience and you know make us
all Gators feel a lot safer about the
project Amazon are pushing forwards with
but
does Amazon really have a history of
making woke television or movies well we
could argue that all day and I don't
really want to get into it but do the
people that shout woke at these things
actually have a point well
to be honest yeah a bit
there has been an awful lot of
negativity around Hollywood and an awful
lot of realizations about what Hollywood
really is
Hollywood has been incredibly sexist
over the last well forever it's been
incredibly racist forever and things
like the metoo movement really Shone the
deplorable behavior of a lot of people
in Hollywood demeaning women demeaning
anybody of color and so on
now I actually think some projects since
the metoo movements Etc have over
corrected they've actually gone too far
the other way in trying to you know tell
us how wrong all of this was there's
also been massive problems in the United
States about race the country really is
divided in lots of ways and writers have
talked about that the problem is they've
talked about it badly instead of being
Supple using metaphors and instead of
getting their message across in clever
ways
I think being like a sledgehammer they
have actually hit the nail firmly on the
head like a nuclear weapon and that has
ruined quite a few projects now people
will say things like oh this shows
virtue signaling again I actually don't
think that's a bad thing it's only a bad
thing when it's done badly and again as
I say when it's done like a nuclear
weapon going off in your face rather
than in the subtle ways it's done when
it's done well
writers have always virtually signaled
writers have always and will always put
their feelings and what they believe
into their work Star Trek has always
been kind of woke it's always tried to
Virtue signal it's always trying to say
this is what the best mankind can be we
should be aspiring to this
it is virtue signaling and it's not
supple
but it was well written it was well put
together and actually most of the time
the things it was trying to talk about
were done through the medium of sci-fi
and done well
a lot of other people say that Wellness
is about politics again though Hollywood
is always had stories and movies Etc
that you can really call propaganda they
were funded in part by the government a
lot of times
the medium of movies television now
social media Etc are used by people to
get their agendas across that's always
been the way and it always will be
now whether that's right or wrong you
could argue again until a cow's come
home I would say personally it's a gray
area but when those agendas when those
political ideologies and when that
virtue signaling is so obvious you can't
actually get past it or see the point of
the story behind it then yeah there's a
problem in Hollywood
I would argue that is a lot of the time
down to just bad writing or blaziness I
actually think there's a serious problem
in Hollywood that there's just too much
television being made that they don't
have the time to actually produce
quality anymore it's all about the
quantity
but movies television
social media
it is a very powerful tool it does
change the way we think it does allow us
to think about these things in different
ways it does help us to understand that
the race issue in America and really all
over the world is still a major problem
and something that we need to tackle the
transgender issue at the moment is a
major problem we need to talk about it
and look I'm going to handle my heart
here 100 honest I don't understand the
transgender issue I don't understand a
lot of the gay and lesbian and problems
in the world I don't care if somebody's
transgender gay lesbian or anything I
don't understand when somebody really
wants to be non-binary but the fact that
I don't understand it is why we need to
talk about it now I don't judge anyone I
never have done I have made too many
mistakes in my life to even have the
right to judge somebody
but I want to understand the problems
that these people are talking about I
also want to understand why my mate my
key is a black guy keeps getting stopped
by the police and I've never been
stopped even once
these are massive problems and sci-fi is
a great medium for exploring them and
hopefully teaching us something along
the way but it needs to be done well it
doesn't help anybody when it's done
badly
so will Stargate get ruined by woke
Hollywood well if Mark Fergus or
somebody along that line a fan of
Stargate actually does Show run this
then I think hopefully we'll get
something good because I do tell you
this one thing Amazon they tend to buy
shows I'm told they don't actually
influence shows a great deal they will
put a team in that they want and then
they kind of let them get on with it so
if we get the right team we will get a
good show
there will be hardcore people that will
shout woke at Stargate regardless of
what the show is like and you'll be able
to tell these people because they'll
start shouting it well before the show
is ever released
ignore them
watch the show with an open mind watch
the show when it is finally aired and
make your own opinion
because at the end of the day even if
this series is woke even if it tackles
transgender issues has non-binary
characters as characters from every
country on the planet
as long as it's written well as long as
they have good stories and as long as
it's heart it's still Stargate it's
going to be a show we can adore now guys
get into the comments and tell me
exactly what you think about this little
rant
how wrong am I how right am I do you
actually think that maybe I'm
underestimating the problem in Hollywood
actually am I overestimating it a lot of
people will say look Hollywood's just
Hollywood it's the way it is it's the
way it always will be
please get into the comments and tell me
exactly what you think about this very
difficult subject if you are new to the
Channel please like subscribe hit that
Bell notification it really helps us out
and you'll never miss any of our new
videos also you can go to patreon.com
forward slash Sidetrack where most of
our new videos air first and for some
more contribution each month you get to
see them without the adverts as always
please stay safe and I'll see you next
time
foreign